this is what happens to aid destined for
Venezuela casualties and panic
a convoy of vital supplies set on fire
[Applause]
[Applause]
some crossed into Colombia to help
risking it all trying to turn murderers
military
[Music]
more than 20 soldiers did desert their
posts a loyal block that looks a little
more vulnerable now Frank wait oh is the
man they recognizes their leader and he
wants to be seen at the wheel
bienvenidos a la correcto
welcome to the right side of history
welcome military who today stood on the
side of the Constitution welcome it is
he told me a turning point the situation
is unprecedented the goal isn't only to
attend the emergency which is
fundamental we've been living under a
murdering dictatorship which murders by
action and a mission
14 trucks left filled with food medical
supplies and hope but look at their fate
it is an invasion in the eyes of Midori
and he's in rallying mode wasting no
time breaking diplomatic ties with
Colombia there is desperation in the air
and no one knows where it could lead
next
Cordelia Lynch Sky News cúcuta Colombia